fascinating
this whole topic there's so many other
questions i had for you but
i just feel like exploring this and
exploring this and just so you know i'm
not someone who's into conspiracy
theories
or strange phenomenon i'm much like
yourself i'm pretty sure that's just
like you
but this is absolutely fascinating and
it's it's even frightening
because what the heck are we like and
now i'm wondering
how much of this is actually just an
experiment by them
because well that to me makes the most
sense as to why they
i don't think convergent evolution would
produce intelligent creatures that look
like us each time i don't think so
it could be the case but i don't buy it
only because we have one data point
and maybe aliens are two data points
strange yeah well the problem is that
the thing the thing that i wonder about
is if they're
if they're dna based right if they have
the same kind of biochemistry that we do
then
then it's hard to imagine that we're not
related
in some way right so
are they from you know so then you start
wondering about all the possible are
they from here which would be very
surprising um are they from here did we
really miss something big
um did they come from here originally
and go somewhere else and are coming
back
did they are they from another
another system where there was some kind
of panspermia
between you know that led to you know
biology spreading from one system to
another so that we're of the same
you know so that we're somehow
biologically related to one another
otherwise i'd imagine you would be very
much
you know the situation you would expect
would be
very much more like what um
stuart kaufman from the santa fe
institute would have described where
you have the biology is probably
very different and you run the risk of
you know you don't want to touch them
because you're going to
you know your biology isn't compatible
so there's going to be all sorts of
horrible chemical reactions
um so you wouldn't want to touch them
yeah well you don't want to come in
contact with their organic molecules
because
you don't know what kind of reactions
you'd have um
so you because well so so in stuart
kaufman's talked about
auto catalytic sets where you get sets
of
organic molecules that auto catalyze
right and
so our biology is basically one whole
system of
of these types of chemicals so we're all
compatible with each other but
if you get another organic molecule in
that's foreign
you know that's going to interact with
different ways and create all sorts of
new types of molecules so
i haven't heard of that before yes that
is stewart kaufman
stuart kaufman yeah model catalytic sets
or auto catalytic
molecules or what auto catalytic sets i
think it was
and he i think it was his book at home
in the universe i believe it is
but you know the implications from that
is if there were
aliens who were truly alien the eu
and they were but they were you know
made of you know they're carbon based
then the chance that the molecules are
similar
is you know are is going to be it's
going to be problematic
you